I mean what's secure I seems like he's
very interested first up I just love his
demeanor in sit at the table this is
gonna be the most exciting video game
you've ever played you're gonna have so
many options I'm dying
overworking myself all day every day to
keep you happy the video had a winner
candid quality because it really did
feel like there like okay not done we're
gonna kind of need you to trust us in
advance but if you decide to we'll give
you some cool yeah happy Saturday I
think reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey John
we're gonna watch a long one today got
quite a few requests for it
oh it's Super Smash Brothers ultimate
direct don't know exactly what that
means I was addicted to the first couple
of Super Smash Brothers games the last
one every time I go at Dan Alissa's
that's what we would play I have friends
who own switches so yeah I'm gonna be
playing the hell out of this one too no
matter how many characters they add just
stick with link Captain Falcon in there
or young like oh yeah from whatever it
can recall this game has like like at
least 10 characters ultimate it's kind
of it's a little a good amount I say you
could cause like over 70 characters it
might be like like including DLCs maybe
up to a hundred I'm not sure what the
exact number is on that little Mac
that's my other top 1/2 and I want to
give one more quick little thank-you
shout out to Tyler Haig who recently for
my birthday he gave me a ps4 pro with a
Red Dead Redemption - it's a bundle kit
thank you again Tyler I'm gonna keep
taking you for weeks on end buddy so
figure video game related video might as
well you know
thanos yeah this is the whole forty
minute video this is language friendly
gamers seven okay Wow all of them we're
gonna go through all seven TM is gonna
be fun hmm damn you really made
something out of that design go back
there's my guy wait was that Ken yeah
[Music]
awesome it's probably ways you do those
combos for smash yeah Taylor's cutscene
graphics
ha now we just gotta get Damien Chapman
claiming the super smash movie yeah oh
man you just got owned dude not actually
I was that new Pokemon character dude
give me a blast like a wrestler
[Music]
you guys like comment and tell me like
what's the stick pokemons
powers he looks like he's got that belt
like that do for my hair I'd be damned
[Music]
that's what game is this property damage
does crotch is on fire
it is it's an STD [ __ ] via did they do
that thing like Civil Works where they
where they cut out spider-man Hey Thank
You Lee from the Street Fighter series
use rival in his original game perhaps
you could say Luigi
is the original let's get back to taking
some crazy breaking that me that
gunfighter reviews like angers turbo as
my scam growing up you
turns up the heat nice the shape of his
head okay is different - oh cool and his
monkey Simbu techno strikes opponents
multiple times pill wheel focus attack
we included lots of Ken's signature
moves such as it's famous case yes
Commandments he's a bit faster than real
and we've also incorporated other tweaks
weirdly I don't - as well as Falco's
five no I'm actually glad they wrote
down the differences it'll pose for the
audience nice that's dope
it's specially this cross chop you'll
leap up and come rocketing back down
damn this attack can be very effective
but if you mess up it's easy to
self-destruct Oh
lariat it's down special is revenge what
damage Zener is burning passion comes to
the surface powering up its next attack
that's in sonars idea look the reactions
to getting hit some malicious music
kappa Tevan faster and we finally
revealed all of the prices you'll find
in the game series user selects Creek
there aren't very many at first but it
is the same amount as the original
Nintendo 64 game and once you've all
this missing - yes for each one's
located but they're sorted by number in
the order they joined the series overall
it's cool it's fun
I hope really enjoyed that way
seventy-four fighters on the roster
every four in the pin roster oh wow
that's a lot of characters well-tuned
Wow
remember the Ridley gameplay that was an
awesome it's kind of scary okay that's
right the ham that's cool
[Music]
this is a greatest commercial ever it's
like infomercial be a great fit for this
game honestly they were really difficult
to develop to that said the Super Smash
Brothers series is one massive crossbow
Kevin thought and got to create
something more a way to enjoy characters
other than fighters richer psyche of
video game worlds here's what we came
out with their calls spirits interesting
and I don't mean the spooky you seem
kinda but it's nice here as mad as we
lends a helping hand to your pipes
powering the mountain back boss you got
your own little like you know ring crew
yeah yeah that's what's up
in the Super Smash Brothers series the
characters have toys in the real world
but they are fighters in the world of
the imagination returning to the real
world is an imagination either their
Braille combinations of characters this
mysterious world the unspeakable happens
many beloved characters lose their
physical forms the tempo Robotnik except
the fighters are turned into spirit a
little to return to the whoa this is a
person not goals there's a massive
amount of wildly different spirits there
are some massive spirits whoa spirits
five dozen offices stronger ones have
the title advanced especially strong
ones are called aces and some are in a
league of their own night legend
[Music]
pioneer spirits power will be added to
the fighter who has to quit interesting
I likes a good spirit these augmented
fighters become extremely powerful so if
you have like liquid snake spirit ears
have a spooky are a little slots you can
assign them support Spears what there's
a whole new thing is late well we're
tag-team hands fighter stats support
spirits lend them additional skills made
of metals once the primary spear and
support spirits are set your fighters
all powered up spear bet the main way to
acquire spirits is to win spirit battles
you'll find a variety of spirits lined
up on the spirit board
choose the one who want to battle when
you do you'll face off against the
fighter whose abilities and personality
are kinda sorta similar to the opposing
spirit in the case of the lakitu is
fighting spirit you'll battle against eg
kuba and a group of small red Bowser's
he's riding high o need that's really
neat here are some examples of otherwise
you can expect
so once you win you collect you can you
can work with that spirit I understand
this correctly sorry we just have like
once I'm in one of these then you can
you know work with or equip that spirit
early that's what they're saying yeah
these were like side battles
how is it a character enhancement though
get some little confused on them I guess
the sense it adds at least one power or
you know asset to your repertoire like
if you get a superior power you don't
have you get to use that power through
them okay so the by Pazuzu say it like
more than just spider enhancement a
character yeah then you gotta have a
little confusing as you get like the
extra spirits who can like help charge
up your health and stuff okay
I get the sense your VA your building
kind of like a weird ring through or
ever confused feel free to call me tell
us what idiots we are yeah
and then next 104 Animal Crossing I have
this animal crossing so much I still
love it and often a little sad to see
them roped into this fighting oh yeah
how should be on the thumbnail yeah
there's so many spirits
[Music]
[Music]
or
oh so you're a buddy I might get this
sister just play this point it's like
Nintendo K but I really want to get feel
like the switch is most within my grasp
I one for myself and do it well you
definitely a whole separate games
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
certain spirits are known as masters you
can beat them to unlock facilities
slowpoke spirits can also be used to
power up amiibo figure players
you must bid them farewell but you can
repeat the process multiple times it's
one great unique collection of
characters from many different series
but just how many of you would you guess
there are 74 lat
whenever you fight against the spirit
the final smash metres enable oh cool
Wow
awesome
the spirit system lets you simulate
battles between characters with more
series than ever before of course
stronger spirit teams may be easier
we've experienced the more you're
powerful wish I was there's unless
you'll be rewarded it pays to have a
fair fight while assembling a team press
the white button for a recommendation
thank God you get the recommendation
stuff like this I'd be like I don't know
yeah it's a lot to choose from this
health system I'm like I'm gonna need
some guidance in real time so
interesting like tag-team kind of thing
you get set up there with oh dude I know
you can play off the shoo-in for
Nintendo's lineup for online gameplay
there's no longer a need to separate
online modes in super fun and for glory
instead matchmaking it's based on three
factors okay for online battles
oh hey these rules can be pre registered
so you can quickly
play style before battle one players
preferred rules will be chosen at random
and all players will fight using those
rules you can also choose not to set of
rules and others
challenge a high GS peaceful such as
100,000 means you've got more points
than 99999 other players your GSP will
change as the total population of
players increases or you're overtaken if
you're yearning for a challenge try
increasing your global smash power so
that you'll naturally and there is a
more serious opponents by the way you
can set a GSP school for each fighter
fighters you haven't used yet will be
assigned a placeholder GSP based on
highness moving Lina
it's one of the other fighters okay if
you repeatedly self-destruct on purpose
you can place a penalty like
disconnected me that saying you're not
very good an ad for spectrum er yeah
you just hear the team going they're
good at play was for so much things
going wrong we got it this has been
tricky and beta-testing smash tags
[Music]
summary sexual puns yeah - together -
they stayed up smashing all night smash
tag this one Chiklis smash tag prints
line speechless
it's notifications to keep popping up by
keeping like stop I'm trying to watch
the video you just be in the crowd I
don't know how I could ever learn from
watching us so what's going on strategy
this is just one of those things where
you see you're like mr. plague control
so many options let me kick in here
there are spots where you can join the
battle wait in line or you can spectate
ha it all depends where you place your
token when you're in a battle arena this
set a cellphone I don't know with the
Nintendo switch online app you can voice
chat with others in battle arenas magic
world where you been man sorry I mean
milady we were up on smash perhaps the
leg listed for you
this pop-up mid-fight be like this
characters from this game like the
camera
was terrifying
this what fatal frame is about the
camera
[Music]
ah I know it's not money Python but it
makes me laugh
[Music]
[Applause]
snake what's going on snake swamp
well plays that guy oh I thought Mario
series yeah Wow
see spring man's the kind of character I
would totally dominate yeah yeah Oh
Willie Oh
mega man want my Protomen t-shirt for
this means oom in that clothes when
you're playing
[Music]
yeah Wow
wow there's a whole new level of
inventiveness characters are like how
the [ __ ] is this guy gonna be in this
game how am I gonna dial but I couldn't
even statement I just have a French
accent like jean-claude huh really love
how they like sometimes roll it actually
they keep the nerve Virtua Fighter each
I push them out of the ring goes so much
like they keep the original animation
just like this is like so you kill
yourself at the end of this video he's
gonna shoot himself find me in the
spirit world it's a guy from ready
player would know his way to leave you
this magic yeah
you can change the music to choose the
music you can save the replay data your
back way oh cool
and now watch this what I'm [ __ ] you
up man
yeah post this on Instagram there's also
menu where you can read those quick tips
and tricks you see during loading
streets when viewing them you can sort
by category or fire
complete challenges to earn rewards this
time each page is sorted by category and
the layout looks more like a comic book
enjoy the records menu tracks your
battle history there are five different
options they somehow figure out how to
make this more of a fighting competitive
game than ever yeah crazy this fee as
you should just be like a fun matchup
now it's like no people like gold this
rack everything this does feel like the
most significant expansion music yeah
well the other ones games are like you
get the point
yeah should buy music tracks let's spend
more time on how to do that 72 languages
[Music]
can you guess which country this
language can you custom select what was
sort of be German could shoe to be
Japanese as the cool addition I brought
the students here different lectures but
I did learn Russian play super Spanish
oh yeah
this and some they'll change
automatically when you dock yonder to be
sure to set both Spanish we've
implemented a radar always the location
of all fighters you can change its
settings including size while it's
limited to wireless and online play
you can make your teammates
semi-transparent so you don't get this
traffic
how interesting that actually would help
it does help yeah because everybody
would pump it up a little bit
is to choose from
[Music]
speaking of me higher-risk let me
introduce you into some new outfits we
added an oh nice
that looks like to put bad hope that
games a lot of fun while there's so much
in here
hehehe Chili's make me laugh
Gundam
yeah yeah give it a mallet I've really
made this like super smash really feel
like an event Jesse yeah
Jesse it feels like a whole like it
feels like a fighting event yeah there's
something I should point out as I said
we've revealed all of the fighters you
can find in the game they are the DLCs
while we've already implemented a huge
roster of fighters this is the Super
Smash Brothers series which means we're
leaving the opportunity open to add in
more fighters as paid DLC since we
already included every fighter from the
past games that means there are no more
fighters to include unless we develop
new fighters from scratch and we're not
talking about
Ecco fighters Freddie Mercury not echo
fighters huh the price of each set is
expect maybe $5.99 but this could change
and all of the music tracks when
creating something like the fighters
pass
idea that's a bit just reveal what's
included
however allow us to offer this context
okay only those who are confident in its
okay so you have the Stars porn
soundtrack in here God finger
it may take around a year or so to
finish producing all the DLC hurry it up
hi if I'm going to pay $25 okay
Luigi took name Russian
every once
Oh excited about that
I've never been more blown away by their
imagination for now we've got another
head start up but it probably won't be
ready until a couple of months after
lunch please stay tuned
[Music]
we're also creating in a needle before
my skirt torture Wow
later today you'll be able to purchase
the game after finishing this contender
go back I hope you go to Nintendo eShop
ok on our official sites everyone in for
a variety of upcoming hands on ok how
many hours you'll need to get through
all those care we go I should mention
that the adventure mode in this game is
nothing like what we came up with for
the Subspace Emissary that said what
exactly caused all these characters to
lose their bodies and transform into
spirits that is a good all begins and
the rest ok then please look forward to
the game's release history I said that
till the end man's leaving the pack
right now that's scary
wow this is their Thanos they're all
gonna snap
[Music]
whoa oh man this is this is the
beginning huh jeolban saved by Fox house
whoa oh my goodness this is
heartbreaking yeah come on come on Kirby
you got her only hope this ride that
star man
herpy Oh No Oh
whoa
oh my goodness
during the soul stone yeah but you
everyone else has done a reaction mr.
[Applause]
Kirby
[Music]
it's like that banana made theme song
was sung in English II whoa
[Music]
[Music]
Oh Kirby so this is adventure memories
gonna have to fight all them
[Music]
so what do you do you go through
adventure mode fighting the evil like
Negev urgings that's what I'm getting
from it
ya know cherry character he shoots the
one that survives
yeah only talks about her
[Music]
whoa but one more thing they forgot is
that if you will play you'll actually
feel the impact of every punch and power
glass you know you'll be in real pain
along with your character the way they
structure this video is really well done
the way they've expanded upon the whole
world of Super Smash Brothers beyond
like you know cooler designs for
characters like everyone was already
pretty jacked about the fact that you
got so many characters in here it seems
like with this video they introduced two
new characters you know one of them
being Ken and you know I like how they
broke down the whole point of like what
EKKO fighters are and then I appreciate
how they broke down the differences
between Ken and Ryu
because fox and falco you're like such
the same thing right I honestly don't
really know what this specific
differences are between playing as them
other than I just want to please tell Co
this time even though it's the same
exact moves in combination I just know
that I do actually do better with Fox
and I don't know if that's a placebo
effect or if their abilities truly are
different okay notice that though for
sure cuz I was like oh cool dammit with
Kenan right love how they like you're
gonna want to play it saving everyone
one place Ryu every game the most
impressive thing about this whole video
to me is the way that they've got me
looking forward to more things than just
sitting down in button-mashing cuz a lot
of the Smash Bros games yeah are pretty
simple and straightforward and this one
feels like oh man you really expanded
well the world of the game the different
abilities you have and your the ways to
customize your fighting style the way to
customize the fighting style they I deal
with the spirits and also the ability to
track things a lot better a lot stronger
because it's like if you're including
this online gameplay world and people
already so competitive with this game
when it comes to versing they've turned
this into a real full-on fighting game
where you can truly compete and truly
track analytics of everything that you
do with your characters and performance
you can level and just a gameplay in
general
that is so beyond fascinating like the
spirit thing was a little bit harder to
grasp onto him I want to like take a
look at that again but it'll get clearer
when you actually get your hands on it
yeah yeah cuz at first I was like that's
because he said it was about a character
like more than justified her abilities
but you character improvement and and
but then like going through it like oh
this does seem really cool so slightly
confused on how it all works yeah it
seems like an awesome addition like
there's just so many more options now
than before it's it's it's overwhelming
it but it but it doesn't seem out of
grasp to eventually understand all the
mechanics of it and know how to properly
work within it and there's gonna be a
lot of cool guides on how to properly
work around it and be able to adjust to
it sometimes you don't get all these
options I'm like I'm never gonna
remember to even think that yeah yeah I
feel like this video does a good job of
introducing these options that are very
much expanding upon the game in a way
where you're like this doesn't seem like
I have to go do this or the game like
really needs me to do it but it actually
seems pretty cool I might want to check
it out yeah I feel like that's kind of
the best way to introduce something like
that cuz with a game like this you're
inevitably gonna have a certain amount
of your audience just wanting to get in
there and fight but then you'll also
have a certain amount of people being
like oh what is the adventure yeah I
think they're clever about this because
they've really honed in on the different
aspects of the fight and yeah you've got
stats and stuff and you've got ways to
like fine-tune your characters now and I
feel like that can make this pretty
engrossing yeah absolutely
plus you can smash tag your smash tag
smash tag all night I mean with secure I
seems like he's very interested for
stuff I just love his demeanor at the
table this is gonna be the most exciting
video game you've ever played you're
gonna have so many options I'm dying and
overworking myself all day every day to
keep you happy video had a weird candid
quality because it really did feel big
they're like okay not done we're gonna
kind of mean trust us in advance decide
to we'll give you some cool yeah button
so we can't tell you all about it you
can especially feel like people the the
team behind this was aware of whatever
hate they've got it in the past am I
gonna keep it like please
check your internet connection a wired
connection will always be strong so call
us don't send us hate mail please God
we're just trying to develop more drunk
a lot of it is developing be patient not
done yet but we need to hype you up now
how to get free sales go well what's the
core I was saying in this video a lot
that I really appreciate it was he
seemed like it was about more than just
bringing in a bunch of new fighters and
having oh he wanted him he wanted things
to feel mixed up and also honoring
character everyone's primarily here for
the fighting of course like it's Super
Smash Brothers you know like I don't
even think about the adventure mode of
the story mode and then you end on that
and and that was so impactful like that
was the one part we were like oh my god
I mean like chills from watching this
terrifying sequence which is like the
ending to something but this is the
beginning of the story you know so it
was the first time where I've seen
something from Super Smash and I've like
played the first two religiously and
then I've like casually played the last
one but then seeing this one like it's
like a whole new level of emotional
intensity that I haven't experienced
ever in Super Smash Brothers saying like
they really have made this world and I
like that they're taking advantage of
that too it's like you could logic that
out as I need some practice and I'm also
curious as to what happened to the
characters you know I'll go do a bunch
of one-on-one fights yeah yeah I feel
like they're getting really clever with
expanding this game in ways that you
might actually want to take advantage of
yeah the cutscene is a great - yeah
animation like I could watch a whole
film with just like why isn't the
Nintendo Cinematic Universe real saying
this for years on the internet D NCU
needs to happen so that way you bring
them all together for the Super Smash
Brothers movie yeah there was making
those Tannis jokes I liked seeing the
kind of graphical punch up - I mean
Nintendo to me has always been the
system I put more yeah into the tone and
you know just the different styles of
games more than you know all the
graphics are insane but it always does
make me happy to see Nintendo leveling
up their graphical capability because
even throughout this game there were
moments or this trailer there were
where I was noticing like textures on
things just the worlds and yeah and that
cutscene at the end I was like oh these
characters look pretty good yeah
and the lighting looks good and stuff
even when they're doing that tutorial
about how you can change it stuff it
looks like it's not just being washed
out or dark and it looks like it's
actual light quality changing so I bet
the engines are better in this or
whatever this looks awesome I can't wait
to play a man this looks like a total
blast I undecided to explore this game
which is something I've never felt about
a smash bros before yeah it feels like
they've leveled up and do a new game
kind of oh yeah no it's an event now
yeah like I mean they've always in a way
been an event but especially now this
feels like an event alright guys well
who's your favorite Super Smash Brothers
character to play ass currently that you
know you and not the ones that are in
you the ones you play for the loser
would go to characters comment below
alright guys well you can subscribe to
the reject nation please click that
notification bell check us on patreon TV
show reactions QA days music video
coverage love to have you become patron
Jake today